well the debate continues this morning  over health insurance among teachers it  was another very late school board  meeting last night where members heard a  presentation from the ccea on that  situation so in their presentation the  education association laid out a  inconsistent history with tht health  a lot of teachers and staff are worried  they're outraged because doctors are  dropping their coverage and bills are  being sent to collection agencies both  current and former teachers stayed late  to express their concerns  i would have loved to teach for another  five to ten years but i was tired of  seeing other educators get ill or die  too young from stress-induced  illnesses i had to make a change to be  able to enjoy my life  last night's meeting only had a  presentation no actin was taken in a  statement released late last night ccsd  said the ccea failed to adequately  explain the problem but also said  teachers deserve an effective  functioning health plan